pour faire marcher le réseau hertzien
rqth des très haute définition
il faut d'abord installer des antennes
en hauteur des antennes reliées au
réseau internet ça représente en
bourgogne franche comté 130 émetteurs le
but étant de permettre aux territoires
ruraux d'accéder au très haut débit dans
les mêmes conditions qu'en ville côté
abonnés il faut également une antenne
extérieure orienté vers l'émetteur le
plus proche des abonnés qui devront
payer une trentaine d'euros par mois aux
fournisseurs d'accès tous les frais
d'installations et d'équipements est en
prise en charge par la région en 2010 8
28 émetteurs sont passés en très haute
définition 8 millions d'euros
d'investissements ont été programmés
pour cette phase de modernisation 54
mille foyers ou entreprises sont
aujourd'hui dans la zone de couverture
du réseau hercules thd